liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen in der bundespressekonferenz
zu der wir heute ganz herzlich
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel bei uns
begrüßen und auch daneben die
stellvertretende regierungssprecherin
ulrike demmer die mitgekommen ist lassen
sie mich bevor wir loslegen für
diejenigen die uns auf einem live sender
verfolgen auf zwei sätzen zur
bundespressekonferenz sagen wir sind
eine regierungsunabhängige organisation
ein verein den journalistinnen und
journalisten angehören die in berlin
über bundespolitik berichten diese
pressekonferenzen hier veranstalten dazu
politiker einladen die sich unseren
fragen stellen und wir sind auch dankbar
dass auch in der pandemien davon rege
gebrauch gemacht wurde und wir eben
heute ich glaube in der pandemie schon
insgesamt zum vierten mal die
bundeskanzlerin begrüßen können frau
merkel wird zum eingang was sagen bevor
wir zu ihren fragen komplette sie haben
das wort ja meine damen und herren ich
freue mich und dank an die
bundespressekonferenz dass ich ihnen
heute wieder für ihre fragen zur
verfügung stehen kann und möchte zwei
vorbemerkungen machen erstens in den
letzten tagen haben wir in teilen
unseres landes schreckliche verwüstungen
durch ein hochwasser erlebt wir trauern
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt um 170 menschen
es gibt immer noch vermisste und der
sachschaden muss zwar noch festgestellt
werden aber er ist immens die bahn hat
allein mitgeteilt dass 600 kilometer
schienen zerstört sind und wir werden
zur behebung dieser schäden einen langen
atem brauchen deshalb ist die
bundesregierung natürlich auch in
kontakt mit den ländern insbesondere mit
den betroffenen ländern um aufbauhilfe
zu planen und natürlich auch gemeinsam
zu finanzieren
gestern hat die bundesregierung bereits
einen betrag von 200 millionen bundes
seit ich für soforthilfe zur verfügung
gestellt die minister scholz und
seehofer haben ihnen das gestern
vorgestellt und wir haben auch deutlich
gemacht wenn das nicht ausreicht wird
dieser betrag natürlich auch aufgestockt
und wir werden in den nächsten
tagen und wochen mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder auch
darüber sprechen wie wir einen
gegebenenfalls gemeinsam einen aufbau
von organisieren und dann auch
langfristig die wiederaufbauhilfe
organisieren
und zweitens müssen wir natürlich heute
auch über die pandemie sprechen die
infektionszahlen steigen seit einigen
tagen wieder und zwar mit einer
deutlichen und wie ich finde auch
besorgnis erregenden dynamik das ganze
wird angetrieben von der delta variante
des corona virus der faktor liegt
beständig über 1 das heißt also wir
haben ein exponentielles wachstum und
das heißt es führt kein weg daran vorbei
dass die vorsichtsregeln abstand maske
hygiene lüften weiter beachtet werden
müssen
sie sind von wirklich großer bedeutung
und auch regelmäßiges testen muss und
wird auch wieder verstärkt eine große
rolle spielen insbesondere in
innenräumen aber dann auch mit dem
schulbeginn in schulen und kitas denn es
gibt ja auch für die bevölkerungsgruppe
der unter zwölfjährigen also für die
kinder noch keine impfangebot und auch
für die zwölf- bis 15-jährigen sind ja
nur sehr wenige in dieser gruppe geimpft
beides die vorsichtsregeln und das
testen hilft die panama entwicklung
besser zu kontrollieren
wir wissen aber alle dass der schlüssel
die pandemie zu überwinden
da ist das einzige mittel das impfen
und wir stellen ja auch fest impfen
wirkt denn durch das impfen werden nicht
nur immer mehr menschen vor einer
infektion mindestens aber vor einer
schweren einem schweren oder gar
tödlichen verlauf gut geschützt viel
mehr verändert eine stetig steigende
impfquote auch die möglichkeit höhere
instanzen als in den ersten drei wellen
zu bewältigen ohne dass in der sich nun
abzeichnenden vierten welle der pandemie
das gesundheitssystem überlastet wird
die inzidenz spielt natürlich weiter
eine rolle aber durch das impfen
verändert sich der inzidenz fährt ab dem
unser gesundheitssystem wieder der
gefahr einer überlastung ausgesetzt ist
je höher die zahl der vollständig
geimpften umso mehr menschen sind vor
einem schweren verlauf geschützt und das
lka
das robert koch institut entwickelt
zurzeit szenarien wann unter annahme
welcher entboten die belastungsgrenze
erreicht wird und daran werden wir uns
natürlich dann auch in den weiteren
beratungen orientieren denn die
überlastung des gesundheitssystems zu
verhindern ist und bleibt richtschnur
unseres handelns von der natürlich auch
sehr sehr viel abhängt denn was dem ziel
dient die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern dient
auch der wirtschaft der kultur der
bildung und damit unserer gesellschaft
insgesamt
wir wollen alle unsere normalität zurück
aber diese normalität erhalten wir nicht
allein die erhalten wir nur als
gemeinschaft zurück und dazu brauchen
wir noch deutlich mehr impfschutz jede
einzelne impfung zählt jede impfung
einer einzelnen person ist ein schritt
ein kleiner schritt zur normalität für
alle und eine impfung ist kein privileg
nur für diejenigen die über den
leichteren zugang zu informationen oder
den schnelleren zugang zum hausarzt
verfügen nein alle bürgerinnen und
bürger zählen für uns gleich und
deswegen möchte ich wie schon bei meinem
besuch im robert-koch-institut auch
diese gelegenheit hier nutzen und für
den impfschutz werden eine impfung
manchen überflüssig erscheinen weil sie
denken dass sie körperlich und
verwundbar sind anderen mag auch eine
impfung bedrohlich erscheinen weil sie
damit keine erfahrungen haben oder zu
wenig informationen bekommen und
deswegen sage ich an alle die noch
unsicher sind eine impfung schützt nicht
nur sie sondern auch immer jemanden der
ihnen wichtig ist um den sie sich sorgen
dem sie verbunden sind den sie lieben
eine impfung schützt
nicht nur gut vor schwerer krankheit und
schmerz sondern auch vor dem
beschränkende maßnahmen unseres alltags
das heißt also je mehr geimpft sind umso
freier werden wir wieder seien nicht nur
als einzelne sondern eben auch als
gemeinschaft ich kann als
bundeskanzlerin natürlich aus tiefer
überzeugung das tue ich ja auch für eine
impfung werben und ich kann auch
versuchen die fragen dazu beantworten
aber ich weiß auch manchmal hilft es
mehr wenn es vielleicht der sohn die
tochter sind die band bedenken ausräumen
wenn es eine kollegin ist oder ein
freund oder jemand aus dem sportverein
oder in der gemeinde und deshalb meine
bitte an alle die schon vom impfen
überzeugt sind versuchen sie auch
mitzumachen noch andere zu überzeugen
sprechen sie miteinander in der familie
am arbeitsplatz im fußballverein überall
wo menschen sich kennen und vertrauen
und werben sie für den impfschutz denn
wir brauchen einander und wir werden nur
gemeinsam die pandemie überwinden
das waren meine einführenden bemerkungen
und jetzt freue ich mich auf ihre fragen
danke dafür ich habe eine reihe von
fragen im saal ich habe auch schon eine
reihe von fragen online ich werde
versuchen es möglichst gerecht zu
verteilen dass auch die kollegen die
keinen zugang zum saal der immer noch
sitzplatz begrenztes bekommen haben zu
ihrem recht kommen
ich möchte sie darum bitten und nochmal
an die regel erinnern eine frage zu
stellen gegebenenfalls eine nachfrage zu
diesem thema und die nachfrage auch
nicht geschickt dafür zu nutzen ein
zweites thema aufzumachen und ich
beginne mit einer frage online gestellt
von jürgen klöckner schließt an das
thema krone erfragt halten sie es für
nötig die für ende august vorgesehene
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vorzuziehen
um eine neue strategie für die
steigenden fallzahlen zu beraten
wir würden ja in ständigem kontakt und
es wird gegebenenfalls sowieso noch mal
eine ministerpräsidentenkonferenz geben
wenn die schadenserhebung abgeschlossen
ist
nordrhein westfalen und rheinland pfalz
und wir mit den ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten darüber sprechen wie
wir weiter in der aufarbeitung der
hochwasserschäden vorgehen und das
könnte dann auch ein geeigneter
zeitpunkt sein um auch über cola und die
sich ergebende situation zu sprechen
wenn es den wunsch auch von seiten der
mehrheit der ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsidenten gibt werde ich mich
dem sowieso nicht verschließen also es
gibt eine bereitschaft aber ich glaube
wir haben im augenblick noch nicht auch
die abgeschlossenen studien des robert
koch instituts aber ich bin offen in die
lage das erfordert kann das jederzeit
stattfinden konkrete planungen gibt es
noch nicht aber es gibt jetzt erste
bitten das früher zu machen und ich
werde mich dem nicht verschließen
die nächste frage irgendwann hat fran
die entwicklung ist in der tat dynamisch
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass wir in
weniger als zwei wochen jeweils eine
verdoppelung haben und sie heute ist sie
in 12,2 sie können sich das dann ja
ausrechnen dass es kann auch jetzt schon
und teilweise haben die länder ja auch
verordnungen darauf will ich auch
hinweisen
es kann auch jetzt schon natürlich
darauf hingewirkt werden dass bei
steigenden inzidenz wieder zusätzliche
maßnahmen eingeführt werden und ich sage
es nochmal man kann immer so weit gehen
dass man schaut wann droht die
überlastung des gesundheitswesens wir
haben aber auch ereignisse wie long
beach wo wir noch viel zu wenig darüber
wissen
das heißt man kann auch versuchen den er
erwert zu drücken
durch die maßnahmen abstand testen so
wie es eben gesagt habe dass damit den
anstieg zu verlangsamen
und dazu haben eigentlich die länder
alle ihre voraussetzungen auch aber wenn
der wunsch besteht noch einmal gemeinsam
zu sprechen können wir das gerne tun
die nächste frage hier im saal hat freut
uns für welches micro entscheiden sie
sich das und bitte gehen sie ganz nah
ans mikro an sachverständige schlecht
mit maske frau bundeskanzler
die nötige also ist die fehlende nötige
radikalität in der klimaschutzpolitik
das größte versäumnis in ihrer
kanzlerschaft gewesen
was werden sie nach dieser letzten
sommer pk eigentlich vermissen was man
vermisst merkt man meistens erst wenn
man es nicht hat insofern ist das eine
frage für später aber ob ich es vermisse
ob es nicht vermisse ob sie anderes
ergibt aber jetzt zu der anderen frage
ich glaube dass wir sagen können dass
deutschland doch gegen oder gegen den
klimawandel vieles gemacht hat mein
politisches leben ist eigentlich
gekennzeichnet ab 1994 als die
umweltministerin wurde von der arbeit
für maßnahmen gegen den klimawandel
und ich habe mir noch mal angeschaut als
sich 2005 bundeskanzlerin wurde da
hatten wir zehn prozent etwa anteil der
erneuerbaren energien an der
stromversorgung heute haben wir deutlich
über 40
wir haben von 1990 bis 2010 die co2
emissionen um 20 prozent reduziert wir
haben sie von 2010 bis 2020 also statt
in 20 jahren in zehn jahren wieder um 20
prozent reduziert und wir haben uns
jetzt vorgenommen im nächsten jahrzehnt
sie um noch einmal 25 prozent zu
reduzieren
das heißt also es ist einiges passiert
und wir sollten nicht so tun als wenn
nichts passiert ist aber gemessen
und da haben sie vollkommen recht
gemessen an dem ziel deutlich unter zwei
grad oder möglichst nahen 1,5 grad
celsius anstieg ist nicht ausreichend
viel passiert das gilt nicht nur für
deutschland sondern das gilt für sehr
sehr viele länder auf der welt und
deshalb muss das tempo angezogen werden
und deshalb haben wir auch ein
klimaschutzgesetz gemacht da nehmen wir
bereits klimaneutralität für 2045
anstreben für deutschland die
europäische union hat jetzt ihre
vorschläge vorgelegt und das ganze wird
mit vielleicht dem team
greifenden wandel den wir kennen von
wirtschaften leben energieversorgung
einhergehen das ist wirklich ein sehr
großer wandel
kombiniert mit der digitalisierung der
auch noch einmal eine wirklich
disruptive veränderung ist ist die
gesellschaft in einem wie man heute sagt
wirklich tiefgreifenden
transformationsprozess bei dem natürlich
auch darauf geachtet werden muss dass
wir möglichst viele menschen mitnehmen
auf diesem weg dann hat die nächste
frage daneben sitzen der jungen darauf
anschließend frau merkel schon in den
neunzigern als umweltministerin wurden
sie auch unmissverständlich vor einer
klimakatastrophe gewarnt darum wie man
eine persönliche frage was hat sie dann
auch als kanzlerin daran gehindert
früher konsequenter und effektiver gegen
den klimawandel vorzugehen
als bundeskanzlerin hat mich erst einmal
sehr angetrieben diese erkenntnis ich
habe mich noch genau an die
vertragsstaatenkonferenz in kopenhagen
oder sagen wir anders ich habe sehr
stark daran mitgewirkt das kyoto
protokoll auszuhandeln das war damals
für uns der ideale die ideale
vorgehensweise das nämlich
rechtsverbindlich völker
rechtsverbindlich jedes land auf der
welt seine reduktionsziele verabredet
und auch international hinterlegt ich
musste dann erkennen dass allenfalls
noch die mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union und ganz wenige
andere die zu den emissionen signifikant
beitragen bereit waren dieses curto
protokoll überhaupt in betracht zu
ziehen habe viele enttäuschungen erlebt
damals dass länder gesagt haben wir
werden niemals rechtsverbindlich etwas
hinterlegen uns als land
rechtsverbindlich international
verpflichten und wir haben dann den
tiefpunkt gehabt bei der
vertragsstaatenkonferenz in kopenhagen
und danach hat man sich für einen
anderen weg entschieden das ist das
pariser abkommen und hat gesagt die
mitgliedsstaaten des pariser abkommens
werden freiwillig ziele vorlegen
und das sind diese
nationalen ziele die jetzt auch
verbessert werden müssen in glasgow
das ganze hat natürlich einen noch
unverbindlichen teil und ich habe mich
dann immer in der europäischen union
dazu dafür eingesetzt dass wir hier auch
verbindliche ziele haben das haben wir
auch wir haben eine verbindliche budgets
das heißt
unbeschadet der tatsache dass sich ja
eben schon gesagt habe dass es gemessen
an der objektiven aufgabe immer noch
langsam geht habe ich sehr sehr viel
kraft in meinem politischen leben dafür
eingesetzt mehr hätten dafür zu finden
dass wir wenigstens diesen weg gehen
konnten und das hat sich eigentlich
durch meine gesamte politische arbeit
gezogen
frage nachfrage haben das papier sagt
klimaschutzabkommen angesprochen
beunruhigt sie es dass ihre eigene
partei in ihrem wahlprogramm die
klimaschutz klimaschutzmaßnahmen
aufzählt ihnen nicht also die zellen
klimaschutzmaßnahme auf die nicht mit
dem pariser klimaschutzabkommen
kompatibel sendet das ist die einzige
partei neben der afg bei der das west
beunruhigt sind das bei ihrer eigenen
partei worauf sprechen sie jetzt an auf
die verrechnung mit mit
entwicklungsmaßnahmen oder aus mit
maßnahmen die nicht in deutschland
stattfinden oder was haben sie ihm unter
anderem und es werden nur ziele es wird
sie zu zielen bekannt klimaneutralität
aber es wird nicht aufgezählt mit
welchen maßnahmen wir als deutschland
das erreichen können unter einer von
händlerschaft geführten bundesregierung
hat dieses wahlprogramm ist nicht
kompatibel mit paris an alle experten
beunruhigt sie das
naja ich sehe erst mal die ziel die
ziele sehr kompatibel mit dem was wir
auch als koalition beschlossen haben und
es wird dann der koalitionsvereinbarung
und den verhandlungen überlassen sein
dass man das natürlich konkret ausfüllt
wir haben eine klare vorgaben auch für
die den zunahme des ausbaus erneuerbarer
energien wir haben einige maßnahmen die
können gar nicht national gemacht werden
sondern die wird werden jetzt durch das
paket 50 5 durchgesetzt bei dieser frage
der anrechnung von
investitionen die man auch außerhalb
deutschlands oder der europäischen union
macht bin ich kritisch weil ich glaube
dass das letztlich von paris nicht
anerkannt wird und dass wir uns mehr
oder vor allem oft maßnahmen
konzentrieren sollten die auch wirklich
mit dem pariser abkommen vereinbar sind
eine frage online gestellt von gernot
heller kurze frage wo werden sie am tag
der bundestagswahl am 26 september gegen
18 uhr sein ich mir jetzt noch keine
gedanken gemacht aber ich werde schon
verbindung zu der partei haben die
helaba deren mitglied ich bin nicht mehr
so nahe steht sie steht mir auch also
sie steht mir nahe und ich bin ihr
mitglied also eine doppelte ein
doppeltes bekenntnis nächste frage hier
im saal frau meier auf der von uns aus
gesehen linken seite frau
bundeskanzlerin herr meier vom mieter
kurier ich wüsste gern von ihnen sie
sind ja als kanzlerin aus ostdeutschland
als biografische ausnahmefall so gesehen
nach 16 jahren regierungschefin un
repräsentant in der bundesrepublik in
der ganzen welt wie wichtig ist ihnen
persönlich überhaupt noch diese herkunft
nach all diesen jahren diese diese
herkunft herkunft ohne herkunft keine
zukunft also natürlich ist mir die meine
herkunft ist teil meiner biografie ich
habe dort in der ehemaligen ddr 34 jahre
meines lebens gelebt und das hat mich
geprägt das ist doch ganz klar und diese
herkunft über die hab ich ja auch
gesprochen und die hat mich geprägt und
ich wünschte mir darüber haben wir auch
oft schon geredet natürlich in der
breite der führungsfunktion in
deutschland noch mehr menschen mit
ostdeutscher biografie mit zunehmenden
zeitablauf relativiert sich das
natürlich weil es diese klassische
ostdeutscher biografie dann ja jetzt für
die
über unter 30 oder 35 jährigen gar nicht
mehr gibt aber ich bin mit mir sehr im
reinen und meinem leben und meiner
biografie und glaube dass sie gute
möglichkeiten gibt beiträge zum
gesamtdeutschen politischen leben zu
leisten
im saal geht es weiter in der mitte
hinten mit ihren gartmann moment ja ich
klicke eigentlich auf das richtige aber
dass hinter ihnen leuchtet können sie
ausnahmsweise das nehmen ein bisschen
fehle vormerken
ich habe eine nachfrage noch mal und
dann eine kleine andere frage mir ist
immer noch nicht klar was jetzt
sozusagen ihr engagement im klimaschutz
und gegen den klimawandel angeht ist der
schuss selbstkritik dabei wenn sie diese
sätze sagen wie es ist nicht ausreichend
viel passiert oder sieht sie wirklich
der meinung dass sie in den jahren ihrer
kanzlerschaft wirklich das maximal
mögliche getan haben in dieser frage und
meine eigentliche frage ist ja gabmann
wir hatten uns vereinbarung eine frage
pro person
die ist ganz kurz tut mir leid dass ich
es sind jetzt schon mehr fragen als
bestellen könnten die sinne der
kollegialität und fertig eine frage ja
ich bin der meinung dass ich sehr viel
kraft für den klimaschutz auf gewandt
habe und immer auch gerade in der zeit
in der ich parteivorsitzende war in der
cdu und sehr dafür geworben habe den
klimaschutz nicht aus dem auge zu
verlieren und ihn beständig voran zu
treiben
und trotzdem bin ich ja mit
wissenschaftlichen verstand ausreichend
ausgerüstet um zu sehen dass die
objektiven gegebenheiten erfordern dass
man in dem tempo nicht weitermachen kann
sondern schneller werden muss und das
ist die dualität dessen was ich sagen
kann aber ich glaube dass ich schon
beachtlich viel kraft und auch mit einer
großen kontinuität eingesetzt habe wir
werden ja punkt
die nächste frage hat frau was hinten
auf der von uns aus gesehen nein ach so
dann war das ein missverständnis
dann ist auch der liste als nächster
herr gas auf der von uns aus gesehen
rechten seite relativ weit hinten
es tut mir leid irgendwie es geht immer
wieder aus und also bei mir hier vorn
ist ja es ist wahr dass man nur noch an
ist das müsste aber automatisch um
springen das ist das problem
es tut mir echt leid das ist jetzt
möglich gesetz dass ausgerechnet heute
unsere tonanlage nicht mehr so richtig
will ich überlege gerade wenn sie
versuchen ihre frage sehr laut zu
stellen tut mir das total leid für die
die in den übertragungen das nicht hören
ja dann ja wiederholen aber ja
vielleicht müssen wir es so
ja also ich teile ihre einschätzung
jetzt bei den impfstoffen und auch bei
corona nicht wenn wir uns im
internationalen vergleich
das mal anschauen dann sind wir beim
informiert sehr schnell vorangekommen
und ich glaube dass es absolut richtig
war nicht als deutschland selber sich
die maximalen impfstoffe zu besorgen uns
alle anderen europäischen länder zu
vergessen
ich glaube es war auch richtig einen
großen teil der europäischen produktion
nicht einzubehalten für europa sondern
mit der welt zu teilen dass es zeichnet
uns aus und darauf können wir auch stolz
sein wenn wir sehen dass wir dadurch
vielleicht ein oder zwei monate später
sind als viele andere länder die gar
nichts weg gegeben haben dann finde ich
ist das alles sehr gut gewesen und jetzt
sind wir an einem punkt wo wir bitten
müssen dass die menschen sich impfen
lassen damit wir die pandemie auch
wirklich überwinden was die bonner den
corona verlauf als ganzes anbelangt so
haben wir sehr sehr vieles richtig
gemacht sowohl was den schutz unserer
wirtschaft anbelangt wir haben unser
gesundheitssystem hat sich als sehr
leistungsfähig herausgestellt wir
konnten anderen ländern helfen in der
pandemie auch unseren nachbarstaaten und
wir haben an einigen stellen einige
dinge nicht so gut gemacht zum beispiel
die altenheime zu schützen das war hat
lange gedauert bevor das geklappt hat
wir haben eine tolle bundeswehr gehabt
viele freiwillige helfer also insgesamt
würde ich sagen sowohl was die
wirtschaftlichen konsequenzen anbelangt
als auch was die gesundheitlichen
auswirkungen anbelangt wenn sich da
vergleichsproben anschauen gibt es viele
länder die den schwierigeren stand haben
wenn sie die digitalisierung ansprechen
dann muss man sagen dass wir besser sein
könnten und sollten es geht zum teil
sehr langsam
das mag damit zusammenhängen dass wir
eine recht gute verwaltung haben die
glaubt
auch ohne digitalisierung weiter gut
arbeiten zu können deshalb bedarf es oft
eines großen kraftakt um hier eine
gemeinsamkeit von bund ländern und
verbunden hinzubekommen das sind wir in
den letzten jahren vorangekommen
aber da gibt es zu tun und da gibt es
länder die zum teil auch kleiner sind
als wir also weniger einwohner haben die
uns deutlich voraus sind wenn island
denke wir in dänemark die
skandinavischen länder denke und da sind
jetzt wichtige pflöcke eingeschlagen
worden jetzt muss es nur noch auch
wirklich bundesweit ausgeräumt werden
wir nicht anders online zugangs gesetz
denke also wir sind ein starkes land das
zeigt sich jetzt das hat sich bei corona
bei den wirtschafts hilfen gezeigt
schauen sie wir haben bei den
wirtschaftshilfen zum teil fast die
hälfte der anträge auf wirtschaftliche
unterstützung in europa gestellt da kann
man wirklich nicht sagen dass wir nicht
ein kraftvolles land sind aber wir haben
an einigen stellen wirklich zu tun um
den hohen standard den wir haben auch
aufrecht zu erhalten und die welt
entwickelt sich wahnsinnig dynamisch
fort wenn sie sich die
investitionspakete des amerikanischen
präsidenten jetzt anschauen zum beispiel
250 milliarden euro in drei nämlich euro
sondern dollar 250 milliarden dollar in
drei jahren für die entwicklung der
modernsten chips und wenn sie das auf
europa umrechnet und sagen wir wollen da
auch welt führen werden dann wissen wir
vor welchen großen herausforderungen wir
stehen einfach diese
entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit ob das jetzt
bei chips bei quantencomputer
batteriezellen usw ist mithalten zu
können und das sehe ich als eine der
zentralen aufgaben auch für die nächsten
jahre an
ich bin froh ich habe immer von 2005 an
gesagt dass ich gerne möchte dass unser
anteil an forschung und entwicklung die
schon 2000 im der lissaboner erklärung
der staats und regierungschefs der
europäischen union versprochenen drei
prozent ausgaben des
bruttoinlandsprodukts zu erreichen wir
liegen heute deutlich über 3% wir lagen
deutlich darunter
das ist schon mal ein guter anfang aber
wir müssen richtung 3
prozent und wir sind eines der ganz
wenigen europäischen länder die das
haben wir sind das europäische land das
die geringste oder mit die geringste
jugendarbeitslosigkeit hat
ich bin bundeskanzlerin geworden da gab
es fünf millionen arbeitslose wir sind
heute unter drei millionen
trotz der krise in der internationalen
finanzkrise der internationalen krone
herausforderungen jetzt also es gibt
viel zu tun aber wir brauchen wirklich
auch nicht unser licht unter den
scheffel zu stellen bevor wir zur
nächsten frage kommen müssen wir hier
einmal in der hoffnung
es hilft uns ganz offensichtlich nicht
was design mikrofone angeht also wir
müssen das es tut mir sehr leid somit
weiter improvisieren mit den
fragestellungen im saal bloß ein
funktionierendes micro da hinten haben
bei herrn gartmann was ich nicht mehr
ausstellen lässt
tatsächlich wäre es eine variante für
diejenigen die nicht immer einfach bei
denjenigen die im saal demnächst eine
frage stellen nummer 23 namen im voraus
zu senden der sich nicht traut willst du
trotz der laut zu sprechen könnte
vielleicht tatsächlich nach hinten gehen
das wäre eine krücke dann unter mit
herrn gartmann den platz tauschen
als nächstes nehme ich jetzt aber
einfach eine frage die uns online
gestellt wurde
und ich sehe jetzt wieder weg gestreut
habe frau marshall von der rheinischen
post fragt sie haben in ihrer amtszeit
etliche krisen bewältigen müssen deshalb
bezeichnen sie fehler als
krisenkanzlerin freuen sie sich über
diese bezeichnung
wir sind zu bewältigen hat ist das ja
meist mit sehr großen herausforderungen
verbunden auch mit gefährdungen von
arbeitsplätzen oder von menschenleben
und ähnlichem insofern ist es natürlich
wünschenswert dass man möglichst wenig
krisen hat aber die welt ist wie sie ist
und politik hat die aufgaben zu
bewältigen die anstehen und da gab es in
der tat eine reihe von herausforderungen
die alle im grunde geopolitischer
struktur waren die internationale finanz
und wirtschaftskrise war keine von
deutschland gemachte krise sondern geht
ja doch sehr stark von den vereinigten
staaten von amerika aus die euro
herausforderung war dann schon eher auf
die europäische union konzentriert aber
gilt auch jetzt nicht in dem sinne von
deutschland aus und
die anforderungen die wir mit den
flüchtlingen mit den vielen flüchtlingen
zu bewältigen hatten hatten auch
geopolitische ursachen und ähnlich ist
es jetzt mit der pandemie das heißt also
was meine amtszeit schon durchgezogen
hat immer ist dass wir halt nicht
alleine mit nationaler politik unsere
herausforderung bewältigen können
sondern dass wir teil einer welt
gesamtheit sind und das ist ja auch das
thema was wir beim klima sehen wobei es
ja nie heißen kann weil alle dazu
beitragen und deutschland nur zwei
prozent des co2 ausstoßes weltweit hat
ist das jetzt eine legitimation zu wenig
zu tun sondern wir alleine werden das
weltklima nicht verändern können wir
alleine werden die pandemie nicht
bekämpfen können aber die art und weise
wie wir es machen kann beispiel sein für
andere dem zu folgen und dass es auch
das verständnis dass wir haben sollten
also ein leben ohne krisen ist auch
natürlich einfacher aber wenn sie da
sind müssen bewältigt werden dafür sind
für politiker politikerinnen und
politiker gehen wir jetzt gleich noch
eine frage online und es können sich
dann für die nächsten fragen entscheiden
ob sie zum mikro gehen vor gammelin herr
stempfle und herr grün wählen dann die
nächsten auf meiner liste
zunächst aber eine frage von thomas
nehls freier journalist er fragt zum
komplex pegasus bedauern sie das
hightech firmen des befreundeten landes
israel klar freier marktwirtschaft die
presse und meinungsfreiheit vor allem im
autoritär regierten staaten untergraben
helfen und was ließe sich dagegen
unternehmen
ich glaube dass es wichtig ist das so
für bestimmte situationen ausgerichtete
software nicht in falsche hände kommt
das heißt das ganz restriktive
bedingungen da sind und dass man eben an
länder in denen eine gerichtliche
überwachung zum beispiel von solchen
angriffen
vielleicht nicht gesichert ist dann
solche software auch nicht verkaufen
sollte berlin die versuchung am platz
[Musik]
ja also das glaube ich war es zu jeder
zeit für einen westdeutschen kanzler ich
habe keine der bundestagswahlen die ich
bestritten habe unter der maßgabe
irgendwie geführt wenn es jetzt jemand
aus den alten bundesländern würde dann
wäre das für die gesamte deutsche
einheit nicht möglich ich meine immerhin
hat helmut kohl sehr gut die deutsche
einheit
gemanagt auch international ja das in
frieden und freiheit und anerkennung und
akzeptanz unserer alliierten und partner
geschafft ich glaube dass dass es
manchmal auch gar nicht so einfach
herauszufinden ist was ist jetzt was was
was prägt man ich bin wissenschaftlerin
naturwissenschaftlerinnen das ist bei
den meinem vorgänger nicht so oft
vorgekommen nicht zu sagen gar nicht
wenn ich recht informiert bin und ich
hatte eine ddr biografie das konnte er
naturgemäß voller wiedervereinigung
nicht durchkommen und das jetzt alles
auseinander zu witzeln ist schwierig ich
habe immer versucht und glaube mich auch
weitestgehend daran gehalten in ost und
west immer mit der gleichen stimme zu
sprechen also nie zu versuchen die
unterschiedlichen reaktionen die man da
findet und den unterschiedlichen kontext
aus dem die menschen ja auch kommen zu
nutzen um dann unterschiedliche
positionen zu vertreten
das führt dazu dass ich nicht immer
allen gefallen habe also wenn ich eine
etwas aus der alten bundesrepublik
mitgenommen habe in die argumentation
für die neuen länder
dann war das oft nicht ganz einfach ob
das nun der eigentumsfragen waren ob das
fragen der biografie von frauen waren im
blick auf das rentensystem ausscheidungs
fragen waren
ob das zusatz versicherungsfragen waren
und was ich einbringen konnte es glaube
ich ein ziemlich gutes gesamtdeutsches
wissen weil ich das von der ddr ja
wusste und bundeskanzlerin kann man mit
sicherheit nur werden wenn man dann auch
alles weiß oder möglichst viel weiß wie
es in der alten bundesrepublik gelaufen
ist es gibt teile die kann ich nicht
mehr nachholen ich bin nie in einem
alten bundesland in die schule gegangen
das heißt ich weiß nicht wie es
sozusagen der bundesrepublik deutschland
mit der qultus hoheit ist ich bin nie in
einem alten bundesland umgezogen einer
ddr wäre das kein thema gewesen weil man
einfach einen zentralen schulplan hatte
und so fehlen mir natürlich bestimmte
bruchstücke aber ich glaube das
gesamtsystem kenne ich recht gut und ich
wünschte mir wenn jetzt jemand aus den
aus der alten bundesrepublik
bundeskanzler wird das einfach ein
großes interesse weiter für biografien
aus der ehemaligen ddr da ist weil die
verletzungen die gefühle die anerkennung
die der kontext das ist alles etwas für
das man sich auch nach wie vor kümmern
sollte um ganz deutschland zu verstehen
hersteller sehe aber durchaus das
bestreben aller kandidatinnen und
kandidaten für das amt der
bundeskanzlerin die genfer
flüchtlingskonvention wird nächste woche
70 gleichzeitig muss man aber anerkennen
dass an der eu-außengrenze sie oft gar
nicht mehr eingehalten wird stichwort
des inputs 6 in griechenland aber auch
dass flüchtlinge an der eu außengrenze
nicht dass gar nicht geprüft wird ob sie
also berechtigt sind manche werden sogar
verprügelt umgang partien sind
stichworte wie bewerten sie das gerade
jetzt zu dem geburtstag der
flüchtlingskonvention erst einmal kann
man glaube ich bin zug und recht sagen
dass europa dort nicht alle
mitgliedstaaten gleich aber wenn wir uns
deutschland anschauen aber auch
frankreich und andere schon einen großen
beitrag dazu leistet dass wir
flüchtlingen
vor krieg und verfolgung asyl gewähren
und damit schon einen viel höheren
beitrag als noch vor einigen jahren
leisten hier auch zu unterstützen
und zweitens muss man sagen dass es
immer wieder auch kritische situationen
gibt deshalb gibt es ja die
untersuchungen auch bei frontex und wir
sind verpflichtet natürlich diese genfer
flüchtlingskonvention einzuhalten ich
bin auch dafür
wir müssen weiterhin anerkennen dass es
nicht ganz einfach ist wenn jemand wenn
es sich erweist dass jemand keine
berechtigung für asyl hat und aufnahme
innerhalb der europäischen union
menschen auch wieder in ihrer heimat
zurückzuführen
und das führt dazu dass wir letztlich
noch kein zustand erreicht haben den ich
mir wünschen würde nämlich dass wir
legale migration haben und dass wir
denen den wirklich geholfen werden muss
helfen können und dass wir nicht
letztlich schlepper und schleuser nach
wie vor in erheblichem maße agieren
lassen die mich immer die menschen die
es wirklich am meisten brauchen denen
helfen und ich würde mir idealerweise
vorstellen dass wir eben wenn wir
menschen aufnehmen die verfolgt sind und
die vor allen dingen auch humanitär in
notlagen sind das eben zusammen mit dem
ohren hcr oder ähnlichen machen und da
sind wir noch sehr weit davon entfernt
außerdem das muss sehr kritisch
angemerkt werden ist es nach wie vor
nicht gelungen für die europäische union
eine gemeinsame asylpolitik festzulegen
und das ist etwas das in den nächsten
jahren unbedingt gelöst werden muss weil
es eine schwere würde für den
zusammenhalt der europäischen union ist
aber sie sehen ja zum beispiel wenn sie
sich anschauen was an der belarussische
litauischen grenze passiert das einfach
mit dem bekenntnis zur genfer
flüchtlingskonvention auch inzwischen
politik gemacht wird von herrn von
seiten von herrn geschenke in einer
weise die auch nicht akzeptabel ist
eine frage online gestellt nämlich mal
dazu von giorgis körpers von
griechischen rundfunk trt erfragt zu
einem außenpolitischen thema vor
ziemlich genau einem jahr schreibt er
haben sie in dem streit um die
gasvorkommen im östlichen mittelmeer und
im konflikt zwischen griechenland und
der türkei vermittelt jetzt ein jahr
später eskaliert mit dem besuch des
türkischen präsidenten erdogan in den
besetzten gebieten zyperns und seinen
ankündigungen die spannung wieder und er
fragt sind die verhandlungen gescheitert
wie stark wird die neue eskalation die
beziehungen zwischen der türkei und der
eu beeinträchtigen
mein grundsatz ist es immer zu sagen
dass sie jetzt nicht vom scheitern von
verhandlungen sprechen
es gibt rückschläge es gibt fortschritte
wir sind glücklicherweise dazu gekommen
dass die explorations gespräche zwischen
griechenland und der türkei wieder
aufgenommen sind es gab jetzt auch
treffen des griechischen
ministerpräsidenten türkischen
präsidenten
wir haben uns immer dafür eingesetzt
diese gesprächskanäle auch aufrecht zu
erhalten und haben gerade im verhältnis
griechenland und türkei
da auch einige kleinere schritte
erreicht das wird jetzt erschwert
dadurch dass gerade im blick auf die auf
zypern
doch der türkische präsident abweichend
von den un resolutionen ausschließlich
auf eine zwei staaten lösung setzt die
wiener griechisch zyprischen seite
natürlich nicht akzeptiert wird und auch
hier müssen wir jetzt wirklich versuchen
diese heuer unter der ägide der
vereinten nationen geführten gespräche
wieder im langen atem und das ist ein
dickes brett was zu wollen ist aber doch
in die richtige richtung zu lenken und
da war sicherlich dass jetzt ein
rückschlag aber von solchen springen
darf man sich jetzt auch nicht
entmutigen lassen wir werden jetzt noch
einmal den versuch unternehmen unsere
technik probleme zu lösen das heißt dass
wir kurz die anlage einmal
neu starten das dauert ungefähr 10
sekunden auf den sendern werden sie
einen test und werden
das mikro abschrauben gut wir sind
wieder da es hat aber trotzdem nicht
funktioniert das heißt wir bleiben bei
diesem verfahren und der kollege grimm
hat die nächste frage an dem mikro das
nicht mehr ausgeht
frau merkel ich wollte sie fragen nach
16 jahren und vielen internationalen
staats und regierungschefs mit denen sie
zusammengearbeitet haben mit welchem
oder mit welcher hatten sie das beste
persönliche verhältnis und warum
nein das werde ich jetzt nicht im sinne
von noten geben beantworten denn wir
sind verpflichtet als regierungschefs
ich als deutsche regierungschefin mit
anderen gut zusammenzuarbeiten
ich habe oft erlebt dass ganz
unterschiedliche ausgangspositionen
trotzdem zu sehr frucht bringen den
gesprächen geführt haben und auch zu
lösungen wo man vorangekommen ist
ich habe erlebt dass ich unglaublich
viel lernen konnte über die kultur
anderer länder und auch das fühlen und
denken in dem man in dem ich mich auf
vertrauensvolle gespräche eingelassen
haben
ich habe menschen getroffen die sind in
hohem maße auch meiner meinung nun
könnte man denken dass dann immer
besonders einfacher ist es ja auf eine
bestimmte art auch aber ich habe es auch
immer als sehr herausfordernd im guten
sinne empfunden menschen zu treffen als
schwarz und regierungschefs die ganz
anders an die dinge herangehen und
deshalb habe ich viele viele gute
erfahrungen gemacht und auch in den
allermeisten fällen erlebt das vertrauen
herrscht zwischen regierungschefs und
dass da auch ab und an kleine
enttäuschung dazu gehören das ist klar
dass ich damals zusammenhang mit nsn
nicht begeistert war es bekannt das hat
aber jetzt einer guten zusammenarbeit
mit präsident obama auch keinen abbruch
getan
die nächsten kolleginnen hier im saal
werden sein nachdem ich aber vorher noch
online fragen stelle um zeit zu geben
die kollegin doudin der kollege rinke
und herr heinrich und vorher nämlich
gleich zwei fragen online zusammen weil
die ein ähnliches thema haben
barbara gillmann vom handelsblatt fragt
zum thema frauenförderung sie seien in
ihrer amtszeit nicht als feministin
aufgefallen hat sich ihre haltung zur
rolle und förderung der frauen in den 16
jahren verändert und gerd joachim von
fallois von phoenix fragt würden sie
sagen dass es deutliche unterschiede
gibt in der art wie frauen oder männer
politik machen und mit dem 2 zu beginn
gibt es auch deutliche unterschiede
dazwischen wie frauen politik machen
also frauen und männer sind ja nicht
irgendwie zwei gruppen die dann alle
gleich sind es gibt verschiedene männer
und es gibt verschiedene frauen und
insofern ist es sehr schwer da
charakteristika festzustellen
tendenziell tendenziell glaube ich gibt
es bei frauen eine gewisse sehnsucht
nach effizienz aber dass da gibt es auch
ausnahmen und insofern will ich da nicht
so charakterisieren was die frage
feminismus anbelangt da gab es ja ein
ereignis im zusammenhang mit dem frauen
treffen von g 20 bei dem dann mir eine
feminismus definition geholfen hat zu
sagen da könnte ich auch für minister
sein
ansonsten glaube ich gibt es wirklich
viele frauen die sehr viel mehr getan
haben für die gleichberechtigung von
mann und frau und trotzdem habe ich auch
einiges auf den weg gebracht und zwar
nicht nur wegen meiner weiblichen meines
weiblichen geschlechts sondern auch weil
ich mit wachsender zeit in als
politikerin gesehen habe das von alleine
ziemlich
nicht geht und das doch immer wieder
maßnahmen notwendig wurden die bei denen
ich am anfang gedacht habe das geht auch
mit nach freiwilligen
selbstverpflichtung und muss schon sagen
selbst als wir brücken gebaut haben und
unsere ersten gleichstellungsgesetze
gemacht haben und gesagt aber jeder muss
einen bericht schreiben und sollte
einmal sagen im nächsten jahren sehe ich
keine steigerung des frauenanteils dann
wird es schon unternehmen sein dass
triftige gründe hat aber dass dann eine
große zahl von unternehmen doch einfach
irgendwie völlig ungerührt schreibt
keine aussicht auf besserung und wir
haben null anteil 0 prozent anteil in
führungspositionen das wird auch so
bleiben das hat mich dann schon auch
dazu gebracht dass wir es dann dass ich
mich dann jetzt zum schluss auch dafür
eingesetzt habe selbst bei vorständen
eine mindestquote einzuführen also das
hätte ich mir 1990 als in die politik
ging alles einfacher vorgestellt muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen wir haben ja wenn
man sich heute noch einmal die
diskussion vor augen führt die gemacht
wurden als wir da bei den aufsichtsräten
den frauenchor um eingeführt haben
da das keine frauen da sind und wie das
alles schlimm ist und so weiter und das
ist in der praxis 0,0 problem ist
natürlich sind frauen da und natürlich
geht das alles und ich bin jetzt froh
dass wir jetzt im grunde auch im
wesentlichen weg sind von diesem drittel
frauenquote sondern dass wir einfach
sagen gleichberechtigung heißt dass der
anteil von männern und frauen gleich ist
im wesentlichen und ich habe auch viel
darüber nachgedacht dass frauenförderung
ohne veränderung männliche
verhaltensmuster gerade bei der teilung
der aufgaben in familie und beruf
überhaupt nicht denkbar ist ansonsten
werden die frauen völlig überfordert
weil sie dann alles super leisten müssen
und deshalb ist es im grunde eine große
veränderung der gesamtgesellschaftlichen
realität die ja bei den jüngeren
familien heute auch besser klappt was
hat ursula von der leyen noch für
diskussionen gehabt als man das
elterngeld auch für väter eingeführt hat
und dann ging das alles prima und aus
dem wickelvolontariat ist eigentlich ne
hoch akzeptierte sache geworden an der
viele familien viel freude haben und
viele junge väter auf freude haben kann
das kanzleramt auch beobachten und das
ist wunderschön zu sehen wie sich da
ganz selbstverständlich die dinge auch
ein bisschen verändern unter den jungen
familien die nächste frage frau
bundeskanzlerin beim bundeswehr-abzug
aus afghanistan wurden die afghanischen
ortskräfte zurückgelassen und sie werden
von den taliban massiv bedroht es wurden
zwar visa ausgegeben aber viel zu wenige
und viele können sich auch den flug nach
deutschland nicht leisten können sie es
moralisch vertreten dass menschen die so
lange an der seite deutscher soldaten
und polizisten gestanden haben einfach
im stich gelassen werden
ich werde mir jetzt gerade im kabinett
noch mal drüber gesprochen unser ziel
ist dass diejenigen die für deutschland
gearbeitet haben
ab 2013 dass die auch die möglichkeit
bekommen wenn sie das wünschen nach
deutschland zu kommen um eben genau
nicht bedroht zu werden ich setze mich
sehr dafür ein dass für pragmatische
lösungen finden so weit dass in unserer
hand liegt und das heißt eben auch dass
der flug nicht daran scheitern darf dass
man das geld nicht hat darüber darum
werden wir uns kümmern und das heißt
gegebenenfalls auch über
charterflugzeuge nachzudenken und ich
möchte dass wir hier denen die uns sehr
stark geholfen haben auch wirklich einen
ausweg geben und man so wie sie es
absolut jetzt gesagt haben dass wir
niemandem helfen so ist es ja nicht es
gibt fälle da ist diese hilfe noch nicht
gelungen
es hat auch das auch nicht ganz einfach
die afghanischen voraussetzungen zu
erfordern aber darüber will ich jetzt
gar nicht einzuhalten hat wobei will ich
jetzt gar nicht sprechen von unserer
seite aus habe ich gerade gestern im
kabinett noch einmal für eine möglichst
pragmatische lösung geworden
trotz nachfrage aber warum passiert das
ganze zu spät ist da viel versäumt
worden bevor die bundeswehr aus
afghanistan abgezogen
erstmals war der abzug zeitraum ihr
natürlich jetzt auch nicht sehr lang das
muss man sagen wir haben in der tat eine
weile darüber diskutiert wie viel jahre
wird zurückgehen
erst hat man gesagt zwei jahre und ich
habe mich dann auch dafür eingesetzt
dass es 2013 ist dadurch ist in einer
bestimmten gruppe sind sie gibt es jetzt
noch menschen die ihn noch nach
deutschland kommen müssen und für die
müssen wir jetzt auch vernünftig
vorsorgen die nächste frage herr ricke
waren es vom platz probieren das
funktioniert wie gesagt nicht das können
sie oder ich nehme meine online frage
und sie hinten das wäre die variante
aber sie kann es einfach probieren ja
nein ich glaube dass die einigung mit
der us regierung nicht die differenzen
zementiert aber es überwindet auch nicht
alle differenzen die differenzen bleiben
das hat man ja gestern aber den
reaktionen gesehen es ist der versuch
zwischen der amerikanischen regierung
und uns sozusagen bestimmte konditionen
festzulegen die ja auch umgesetzt werden
müssen und deutlich zu machen dass
gerade von deutscher seite aus uns sehr
wichtig ist dass die ukraine transplant
bleibt dass sie das energie eben hier
nicht dazu genutzt werden kann dass die
ukraine in eine schwierigere situation
kommt und das abkommen ist oder der text
ist abgeschlossen mit der amerikanischen
regierung
der amerikanische kongress ist natürlich
noch mal eine davon zu trennen
institutionen wie meine absprachen mit
anderen ländern ja auch nicht
automatisch dazu führen dass der gesamte
deutsche bundestag sagt das findet er
jetzt richtig und gut dass heißt hier
bin ich froh dass uns das jetzt so weit
gelungen ist und wir auch eine ganze
menge natürlich auch aufgaben haben
insbesondere zu schauen wie können wir
auch längere vertrags zeiten für die
ukraine noch erreichen und vor allen
dingen die können wir auch den
transformationsprozess der
energieversorgung in der ukraine
unterstützen und wie können wir auch die
anbindung durch reverse flow der ukraine
an europäische gas versorgungssysteme
voran bringen also ein guter schritt der
auch kompromissbereitschaft von beiden
seiten erfordert auf dann erfordert hat
auf der anderen seite aber nicht alle
divergenzen die am tag davor bestanden
überwindet
na ja wir haben ja wir haben jetzt den
bau von horst und dann haben wir den
genehmigungsprozesse für hinaus stimmt
für die betriebsgenehmigung dann haben
wir das energie binnenmarkt paket wo ja
immer auch anforderungen an die gas
betreiber da sein müssen und dann haben
wir natürlich auch die möglichkeit von
der ich nicht gebrauch machen möchte
aber die wir immer haben im zusammenhang
der krim oder mit den jetzt und lugansk
aber auch die möglichkeit sanktionen zu
machen also wir sind ja nicht ohne jedes
mittel etwas zu tun und die erklärung
macht ja auch deutlich dass wir davon
hoffe ich nicht juristische seite hört
dann noch mal gesagt sie will energie
nicht als waffe einsetzen dass es ist ja
auch eine aussage denn niemals in bei
wort aber die das heißt also nicht dass
wir vollkommen wertlos sind von unserer
seite aus wenn wir die politischen
rahmenbedingungen in denen dieses
projekt abläuft uns anschauen
eine frage dazwischen online gestellt
von ich hoffe ich spreche richtig aus
nur wozu naga von der japanischen
nachrichtenagentur sie fragt es zu
stichwort atomausstieg halten sie die
entscheidung zum atomausstieg immer noch
für richtig angesichts des klimawandels
denken sie nicht dass die entscheidung
im nachhinein zu rasch waren
ich halte sie für richtig
jedenfalls als deutsche bundeskanzlerin
für die bundesrepublik deutschland es
gibt länder die entscheiden sich anders
und werden damit auch an einigen stellen
es einfacher haben die klimaneutralität
zu erreichen ich halte trotzdem in der
lange sicht die kernenergie für keine
nachhaltige energieerzeugungsform wir
haben schon erhebliche diskussionen
innerhalb der europäischen union über
die rolle der kern
energie ist auch sehr interessant mit
tridays for future zu sprechen über die
rolle der kernenergie
da ist also sagen wir mal schon die
klimaneutralität sehr stark im
vordergrund angesichts der großen
herausforderungen für deutschland sind
die würfel gefallen wir haben uns für
den ausstieg aus der kernenergie
entschieden und ich sehe nicht voraus
dass irgendeine zukünftige
bundesregierung das nochmals verändern
wird angesichts unserer gesamt haltung
aber wir müssen dann eben auch sehr
konsequent die erneuerbaren energien
aufbauen denn wir und wir brauchen für
eine übergangszeit noch das erdgas dass
es ist die folge davon weil erdgas
natürlich sehr viel umweltfreundlicher
ist als die kohle und insofern können
wir also jetzt nicht wie manche fordern
aus der kernenergie aussteigen aus der
kohle aussteigen und dann auch noch aus
dem erdgas möglichst sofort aussteigen
das wird nicht möglich sein wir müssen
mit allem nachdruck an der produktion
von grünem wasserstoff arbeiten auch
hier haben wir eine menge
fragestellungen darf man zwischendurch
noch ein blauer wasserstoff herstellung
arbeiten dann neige ich dazu das nicht
völlig auszuschließen um einfach die
skalierung besser hinzukriegen und zu
lernen wie man wasserstoff überhaupt
produziert aber auch darüber wird es
weiter wie jetzt schon verschiedene
auseinandersetzung geben insgesamt also
ein ganz klares bekenntnis dazu dass ich
den ausstieg aus der kernenergie für
deutschland für richtig halte
bevor herr heinrich die nächste frage
hat der hinweis die nächsten drei frager
fragerin sind die beiden kolleginnen in
der reihe davor deren namen ich leider
nicht parat habe ich schaue sie gerade
an und herr schuster
und dann hat jetzt erst mal herein
richtigen ist zu fragen was denn eine
marien verwurzeln frau bundeskanzlerin
ich möchte mal zum klimaschutz nachhaken
sie haben gesagt man soll nichts zu tun
als wäre nichts passiert jetzt gibt es
gerade junge menschen unter anderem die
100.000 die vielfältigste future auf die
straße gehen die sagen der breite der
politischen landschaft und gerade bei
den parteien in den nahe stehen die sie
gesagt haben hat man nach wie vor nicht
begriffen wie dramatisch die lage ist
und wie dringend es ist mehr zu tun
was ist die antwort auf die vor diesen
vorwurf
meine antwort ist so wie es erst schon
gesagt habe dass 40 prozent erneuerbarer
energien sicherlich noch nicht
ausreichend aber immerhin doch ein
deutlicher fortschritt gegenüber zehn
prozent sind und dass wir wenn wir das
politisch sehen auch menschen ermutigen
müssen den weg weiter zu gehen und nicht
nur zu sagen was noch nicht ausreicht
auf der anderen seite ist die
wissenschaftliche evidenz und das ist ja
das vorüber wäre wobei ich wenn ich
vertreterinnen von freundes for future
treffe oder vertreter ja auch immer
widerspreche die wissenschaftliche
evidenz mahnt zu noch mehr eile und wir
als politikerinnen und politiker müssen
dafür mehrheiten finden das ist unsere
aufgabe
und das ist manchmal nicht ganz so
einfach denn die die befreit ist for
future sitzen sind ja für uns
antriebskraft das ist positiv aber sie
sind halt nicht die einzige meinung die
in deutschland existiert und jetzt würde
wahrscheinlich luisa neubauer sagen dann
muss ich mich halt mehr anstrengen und
dann würde ich sagen dass ich mich
anstrenge und versuche auch zu
überzeugen aber wir brauchen dafür auch
parlamentarische mehrheiten und für die
zu kämpfen ist meine aufgabe und da
wünsche ich mir natürlich auch manchmal
dass es etwas schneller geht auf jeden
fall darf man das gesamtziel nicht aus
den augen verlieren deshalb ich auch
gerade dieses einfordern der jugend für
sehr wichtig halte denn das gibt ja
durchaus große erfolge wenn man das
bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil denkt
ist das ja wegweisend gewesen und hat
uns dann noch mal sozusagen ermutigt
auch parlamentarische mehrheiten dafür
zu finden dass wir stärker angehen
können an die co2 minuten eine rückfrage
auch wenn sie eine entscheidung heute
aus ihren 16 jahren franz vertrag zum
klimaschutz anders treffen könnten
welche wäre das
wenn wir diese fragen mit der einen
entscheidung also ich habe sehr lange am
kyoto protokoll festgehalten
das war ein fehler weil das nicht
durchsetzbar war dass man das
verbindlich international macht recht
hätte man diesen weg mit freiwilligen
verpflichtungen schneller gehen sollen
und wäre dann schneller beim bei sowas
wie dem pariser abkommen angelangt und
ansonsten fehlt uns etwas nach wie vor
wo er hoffe ich noch keine antwort
gefunden haben wir alle noch nicht wir
müssen den menschen im ländlichen raum
die ja die aufstellung der
windkraftanlagen zu verkraften haben und
auch die solaranlage kommt ja sehr stark
dort her aber vor allem die windkraft
die ja doch ein zentraler punkt ist wir
müssen versuchen auch die an den
segnungen also an den guten zu
beteiligen ist uns bis jetzt noch nicht
gelungen und dass leute die neue energie
transport grape leitungen also diese hgs
und ähnliches haben deren lebensqualität
sich ja objektiv verändert und für viele
aus deren perspektive auch
verschlechtert für die sozusagen ein 1 1
auch ein incentive ein anreiz zu setzen
dass das für etwas wichtiges so gut ist
dann hätten wir weniger widerstand bei
den ganzen planungen und ausbauten und
dann würde das schneller gehen und dann
die frage wie kriegen wir unsere energie
leitung hin und wie kriegen wir mehr
ausbau von windenergie wird uns sehr die
nächsten jahre auch wirklich begleiten
frank jordans von abgefragt auch zum
thema klima glauben sie dass das
politikern vor allem vor der wahl schwer
fällt den wählern klar zu benennen wie
drastisch die veränderung sein müssen um
das pariser klimaziele zu erreichen
das glaube ich nicht weil ja doch im
wettstreit der parteien alle sagen was
passieren muss also wir brauchen
mehr energieleitungen wir brauchen mehr
erneuerbare energien und das wollen wir
aber trotzdem alles innerhalb eines
rechtsstaats machen also wir wollen die
klagemöglichkeiten für bürgerinnen und
bürger ja auch nicht zu null machen wir
haben zum teil instanzen eigene spaß
weil wir gesagt haben das sind
strategisch wichtige konzepte und
infrastrukturprojekte aber ich glaube
schon dass wir sehr deutlich sagen wie
sich die dinge verändern werden und wir
müssen gucken dass das ganze sozial
gerecht zugeht und diese sozial der
faktor der sozialen gerechtigkeit ich
habe eben über stadt und land gesprochen
ich könnte jetzt auch über ausgleich
sprechender wird die debatte sehr stark
bestimmen und das was wir was ich immer
auch wieder sage und manchmal auch
widerstände auch in meiner eigenen
partei überwinden
ich kann nicht eine klima also der
bepreisung von co2 entführen und
anschließend eine carbon leakage
verordnung machen sie jeden der etwas
mehr zahlen muss sofort wieder das
zurück gibt sondern ich muss versuchen
durch intelligente technologische
lösungen neue wege zu gehen und das muss
an gereizt werden also die totale
kompensation für jeden kann es nicht
geben sondern wir müssen ja das ganze
dahin drängen wir können zuschüsse geben
wir können anreize geben aber wir müssen
ja anlass zum schluss unsere energie
erzeugen unsere wohnung dämm und vieles
andere mehr
wie gesagt manche ist es in gang
gekommen man vieles muss sehr viel
schneller gehen dann machen wir im saal
weiter
dank berliner gleitsmann vom orf frau
bundeskanzlerin das ist heute vermutlich
letzte sommer pressekonferenz sehr noch
wenige wochen als bundeskanzlerin wie
fühlen sie sich denn dabei stellt sich
da schon wehmütige nostalgische gefühle
ein und worauf freuen sie sich denn an
den meisten auf ihre
für diese zeit als privatperson angela
merkel ja ich finde dass jede woche ja
nach wie vor mich schon sehr fordert
wenn man jetzt mal die ereignisse
ansieht wir sind in einer situation wo
infektionszahlen wieder steigen wir
haben jetzt dieses schreckliche
hochwasser also ich kann nicht sagen
dass die aufgaben im augenblick nicht da
sind die man zu lösen hat wir haben
eigentlich die phase der gesetzgebung
abgeschlossen und machen jetzt
vielleicht noch mal wieder ein gesetz
wenn das notwendig sein sollte um den
fonds zu speisen mit den bundesländern
zusammen also ich werde und bin
gefordert und das wird sich auch bis zum
letzten tag meiner amtszeit fortsetzen
und das will ich auch so machen die es
immer gemacht habe und deshalb ist auch
wenig zeit und raum sich jetzt irgendwie
mit der zeit danach zu beschäftigen die
wird kommen
ich habe noch nicht bei so als ob fans
universitäten kleinen einblick gegeben
darüber hinaus fällt mir jetzt auch
nicht viel ein
aber ich darf ihnen sagen dass ich auch
für die verbleibende zeit in der ich
bundeskanzlerin bin die arbeit gerne
mache und trotzdem die herausforderungen
jetzt nicht gleich null sind sondern
durchaus gewaltig in vielerlei hinsicht
sie haben wir haben jetzt hier ganz viel
über klimaschutz gesprochen und wir
haben in europa die verhandlungen
vorzubereiten
die verhandlungen für das paket von 50 5
also für das kurspaket der europäischen
union werden ja in die zeit fallen also
ab september in der in deutschland die
hochphase des wahlkampfs ist und dann in
der die regierungsbildung stattfindet
und es wird jetzt ganz wichtig sein
ohne irgendeiner oder oder ohne einer
neuen regierung vorzugreifen
positionierung der bundesregierung auch
immer zu haben die uns keine nachteile
bei den verhandlungen jetzt bringt in
der zeit des übergangs senders wollen
wir nicht wir müssen gucken dass wir
dort selber gute angebote machen für die
klima reduktion bei uns wir müssen aber
auch gucken dass es insgesamt gerecht
zugeht innerhalb der europäischen union
und andere werden für ihre positionen
auch sehr stark kämpfen
und da ist vom auto bis zu
bis zu den rvc ring und den vielen
vielen fragen das sind ja über zehn
rechtsakte die wir bearbeiten müssen und
da werde ich auch noch mal sehr einen
blick darauf haben dass wir da eine gute
übergabe machen an die nächste
bundesregierung also noch keine freude
auch ausschlafen oder memoiren schreiben
will ich habe mir auf meine johns
hopkins aussage hingewiesen wird dann
schon mit der zeit was anfangen bringt
die von new york times
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben eben
erwähnt wie zerstritten das wissen
amerika zwischen der bundesregierung und
den kongress in der gesellschaft gehen
die streiten auch weiter aber man sieht
auch in deutschland dass die
gesellschaft immer wieder spaltet machen
sie sich sorgen um die demokratie im
westen und was meinen sie dass wir
dagegen tun haben unsere offenen
gesellschaften sind schon unter großem
druck
ich glaube dass es sehr wichtig ist dass
wir eine möglichst gute soziale kohärenz
haben also das was wir in deutschland
mit sozialer marktwirtschaft beschreiben
das halte ich schon für etwas sehr
wichtiges das also nicht man wird nie
das erreichen dass alle sich gerecht
behandelt fühlen das ist ja auch der
politische wettbewerb wer kann deshalb
überzeugen aber ich glaube schon dass
man menschen gegen bestimmte risiken gut
versichern muss und ihnen damit auch die
möglichkeit gibt an ihr an der
gesellschaft nicht zu verzweifeln weil
sich vernachlässigt zu führen
das zweite ist dass ich sehr dafür
plädieren dass gesprächsbereitschaft
erhalten bleibt und da wo
gesprächsbereitschaft verloren geht wo
die politische auseinandersetzung so
hart wird und auch immer in persönliche
herabwürdigung endet da endet oft dann
auch die möglichkeit überhaupt noch
brücken zu bauen und das sehe ich schon
mit sorge sowohl in deutschland als auch
in anderen ländern
und deshalb ist sozusagen die die die
politische aussage dass der kompromiss
etwas konstitutives jeder demokratie
sein muss und nicht der kompromiss als
solcher schon etwas schlechtes ist
mit der schlechten kommunikation
behaftet ist das finde ich ist ein ganz
ganz wichtiger kampf und ich gehen werde
ich immer führen dass der politische
kompromiss das machbare ist und das
notwendige ist um gesellschaften
zusammen zu halten weil wir nie alle
morgens aufstehen werden in einer
gesellschaft und die gleiche idee den
gleichen gedanken haben das ja gerade
das spannende dass die menschen
unterschiedlich sind
das zweite was uns das dritte noch was
uns durch die digitalisierung jetzt
natürlich erhebliche schwierigkeiten
macht und was auch sozusagen die
grundlagen der aufklärung fast ein
bisschen in frage stellt das ist dass
gefühle oder emotionen fakten mit fakten
vermischt werden und das sind zwei
unterschiedliche kategorien fakten sind
fakten und die müssen beachtet werden
und die kann ich nicht sozusagen gegen
gefühle aufregen weil mir etwas nicht
passt halte ich irgendwas was objektiv
richtig ist nicht für richtig
sondern ich muss gefühle natürlich
achten sowie in einer guten zeitung weiß
nicht ob früher und heute noch
sachverhalt und kommentar zwei
unterschiedliche kategorien sind so ist
es wichtig dass wir als aufgeklärt
westliche gesellschaften auch die fakten
basiert unsere argumentation hochhalten
eine frage dazu online gestellt von
malte kreutzfeldt
er fragt er schreibt ihr möglicher
nachfolger armin laschet habe das
wissenschaftsverständnis derart die
teilweise gelobt er stelle die
klimabilanz
da und scheinen nicht so verstehen wir
exponentielles wachstum funktioniert
macht ihnen das als
naturwissenschaftlerin sorgen
das kann ich jetzt nicht bestätigen dass
ich glaube wir alle haben inzwischen das
exponentielle wachstum verstanden auch
parteiübergreifend ich glaube bei der
wissenschaft ist es so natürlich
also ich hab eben ja gesagt es gibt
objektive gegebenheiten und die muss
müssen akzeptiert werden und
wissenschaft hat eine arbeitsmethode die
muss sauber und in sich schlüssig sein
und trotzdem kommen können
wissenschaftler auch zu
unterschiedlichen ergebnissen kommen es
gibt die wissenschaft aber es gibt nicht
die gleichheit der des ergebnisses
wissenschaftlicher überlegungen sondern
gerade in den geisteswissenschaften kann
man natürlich durch sehr saubere
wissenschaftliche arbeit sehr
unterschiedliche ergebnisse haben und
selbst in den naturwissenschaften gibt
es ja lange wissenschaftliche streit
darum was jetzt wirklich richtig und was
überprüfbar ist und was nachweisbar ist
und insofern ist mir nur sehr wichtig
dass wir unterschiedliche
wissenschaftliche meinungen akzeptieren
können aber die wissenschaftliche
methodik schon klar sein muss und nicht
jeder sich als wissenschaftler
bezeichnen kann
bevor herr reitschuster die nächste
frage stellt für die nächste runde
können sich dann entscheiden ans mikro
zu gehen oder vom platz laut zu stellen
die frage herr steinkohle frau
rosenfelder und herr köhler che
erreichte
nachgesagt werden alle menschen in
deutschland eine im angebot
rechtliche und politische keine
rechtfertigung mehr irgend eine
einschränkung 18 sie komplett anders als
also wir werden ende juli anfang august
nicht für jeden menschen eine
impfangebot haben weder für die kinder
von null bis elf noch eine empfehlung
der stiko für die kinder von 12 bis 15
und es wird immer in unserer
gesellschaft menschen geben die per se
nicht sich impfen lassen können oder
auch keine immunantwort entwickeln auch
diese gruppe dürfen wir nicht außer
betracht lassen und deshalb ist dann
auch immer noch rücksicht zu nehmen auf
diese gruppen in unserem verhalten
insofern sehe ich das schon etwas
differenzierter aber ich glaube dass die
bundesregierung sich noch immer auf
vernünftige maßnahmen geeinigt hat und
das werden wir auch weiter tun
dass sie schon gibt es außer rissen bei
ihnen überhaupt noch irgendwas
zusammenhängen ist also ja also ich für
meine beobachtung sind etwas an meiner
natur
wir haben natürlich immer wieder
verschiedene schwerpunkte auch und und
schlussfolgerung was muss jetzt welchem
zeitpunkt passieren also nochmal der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat gesagt
dass wir jedem der sich impfen lassen
kann und für den einen impfstoff
zugelassen ist das für die linien auch
ein ins angebot besteht und das ist mit
ende juli der fall
im augenblick haben wir ja deshalb habe
ich ja meine eingangs worte so gewählt
wie ich sie gewählt habe da im
augenblick haben wir ja ganz klar er die
aufgabe fürs impfen zu werben die
impfbereitschaft abzurufen indem wir zu
den menschen gehen und nicht die emv
angebote so fern von den menschen machen
dass sie davon keinen gebrauch machen
deshalb die vielen mobilen teams usw
und ansonsten was die augenblickliche
corona maßnahmen anbelangt sehe ich
keine unterschiede zwischen armin
laschet und mir und wenn die instanzen
steigen werden wir auch alles daran
setzen die gemeinsame lösung zu finden
die nächste frage herr steinkohle
dann ist aber keine sommer
pressekonferenz mehr
jede art von befragung oder jede art von
auftritt für eine bundeskanzlerin
erfordert immer sorgfältige vorbereitung
und ich habe mein amt immer so
verstanden und werde das auch bis zum
ende so tun dass ich die termine mit
freude oder zumindest mit einer
positiven erwartungen und einer guten
grundstimmung wahrnehmen und dazu gehört
auch die sommerpressekonferenz und es
ist ja auch spannend weil sie ich weiß
ja nie was sie fragen und insofern ist
es ja auch eine überraschung immer
wieder und das macht auch freude
dann kommt die nächste überraschung von
frau rosenfelder rosenfelder das ist
tatsächlich echt schwierig zu verstehen
sind wahrscheinlich wäre es besser sie
gehen ans mikro dann lassen sie sich
aber zeitlich nicht mehr eine frage
dazwischen die online gestellt wurde von
ahmad händen rudolf nachrichtensender
außen sind wieder in der außenpolitik
dass veränderungen sind so darf
nachrichtensendern es wahrscheinlich ein
mitglied über den verein der
auslandspresse
er fragt deutschland hat während ihrer
amtszeit die kunden im kampf gegen
gegend gegen den es unterstützt glauben
sie dass diese unterstützung
weitergeführt werden muss damit die
menschen dort nicht flüchten müssen auch
mit blick auf die unterstützung der
gegen die schiitischen gebieten
ja wir haben uns immer bemüht sowohl die
sie duschen menschen als auch die kunden
da wo sie unterdrückten angegriffen
werden zu unterstützen und im rahmen
unserer möglichkeiten und auch der
parlamentarischen beschlüsse werden wir
das mit sicherheit fortführen aber ich
kann jetzt den parlamentarischen
beschlüssen der zukunft nicht vorgreifen
aber für mich ist das eine wichtige
sache denn jetzt groß
die rosenfelder von bild.de
bundeskanzlerin nach dem bericht unseres
reporters stehen in kabul tausende vor
dem passamt und wollen nach europa vor
allem nach deutschland sehen sie 2015
eine moralische verpflichtung diese
menschen die vor dem terror der taliban
fliehen
bei uns aufzunehmen wir haben ja die
erst schon mal über das thema ortskräfte
und menschen die uns als deutsche
geholfen haben mit bei unserem
bundeswehreinsatz in afghanistan
gesprochen und wir haben ja auch schon
sehr viele afghanische flüchtlinge
aufgenommen aber ich glaube man muss
sagen wir müssen anders an die sache
herangehen wir müssen alles tun um
gerade auch die politischen
verhandlungen
in afghanistan voranzubringen damit
menschen eben möglichst in frieden leben
können in dem land und deutschland hat
seine verantwortung im blick auf genfer
flüchtlingskonvention sowie ihr das
gesagt haben immer wahrgenommen aber wir
können sicherlich nicht alles wasser und
in afghanistan an schwierigen passiert
jetzt als deutschland wieder
kompensieren wir haben ja sehr viel
getan wir wollen unsere
entwicklungszusammenarbeit dort
fortsetzen dann möglichst viele auch zur
schule gehen können vieles andere
aber es gibt auch sehr bittere
erfahrungen und zu wie sie es in
afghanistan gibt gibt es sie auch leider
in anderen ländern der erde und nicht
alle diese probleme können wir dadurch
müssen dass wir die menschen aufnehmen
bevor jetzt herr klatsch vielleicht die
nächste frage hat für die nächste runde
schon mal die namen und ich finde von
hier vorne also es wäre wirklich eine
empfehlung an das funktionierende mikro
zu gehen das ist doch deutlich besser zu
verstehen vor allen dingen auch für die
kollegen an den livestreams in der
nächsten runde
während das herr strack frau romanisch
und der kollege hier vorn in der mitte
aber er quatscht versucht jetzt noch mal
seinen platz
sie kennen ja unsere programme die wir
zu den wahlen nicht jetzt erst jetzt
geschrieben haben sondern schon über
viele jahre und sie kennen auch meine
politische meinung dass ich eine
mitgliedschaft der türkei in der
europäischen union nicht gesehen habe
und auch nach wie vor nicht sehe mich
aber trotzdem für sehr gute beziehungen
mit der türkei einsätze und deshalb auch
dafür stark gemacht habe dass das was ja
auch an dem flüchtlings abkommen mit der
türkei steht zwischen der eu und der
türkei
dass wir die gespräche über die
zollunion zum beispiel aufnehmen wir
haben die kommission mandatiert jetzt an
einem solchen mandat für gespräche mit
der zollunion zu arbeiten
wir haben uns jetzt nochmal beim letzten
europäischen rat entschieden drei
milliarden mehr für die unterstützung
der türkei zu geben für die arbeit mit
den flüchtlingen und genau über diese
themen bin ich mit herrn erdogan im
gespräch ich glaube nicht dass wir
flüchtlinge als politisches instrument
einsetzen sollten das sind menschen die
türkei kümmert sich in herausragender
weise
gerade syrische flüchtlinge hat dort
unglaublich viel geleistet wir haben sie
dabei unterstützt aber natürlich nur zu
einem kleinen teil
und ich möchte dass dieses abkommen mit
der türkei fort entwickelt wird das ist
für die betroffenen menschen das beste
eine außenpolitische frage die online
gestellt wurde von herrn jörg butt
deutsche welle er fragt welchen rat
bezüglich der beziehungen zu russland
würden sie ihrer nachfolgerin oder ihrem
nachfolger im kanzleramt geben wie soll
man sich verhalten um ein gespräch mit
dem russischen präsidenten klaren kopf
zu behalten so wie mit jedem anderen
land führen wir unsere gespräche immer
auf der basis unserer werte die wir in
deutschland leben und unsere interessen
die wir haben und ich glaube dass wir
immer ein interesse daran haben sollten
mit russland im gespräch zu bleiben
wenngleich die werte die unser
politisches handeln dann auch bestimmen
zum teil sehr unterschiedlicher sehr
unterschiedlich sind wir nicht daran
denke das habe ich auch es bedauernd und
kritisch angemerkt gestern wieder wie
die nichtregierungsorganisationen im
petersburger der petersberger dialog
jetzt eingeschränkt wurden in ihrer
mitarbeit was im grunde die
zivilgesellschaftlichen kontakte sehr
erschwert dann ist das ein schwerer
rückschlag aus meiner perspektive für
die deutsch-russischen beziehungen aber
das führt mich dazu nicht mehr mit dem
russischen präsidenten zu sprechen das
heißt also auseinander zu halten dass es
sehr sehr komplizierter und schwierige
situationen gibt dass wir auch natürlich
im zusammenhang mit sco und der ukraine
sehr unterschiedliche meinungen haben
aber trotzdem immer im gespräch zu
bleiben und zu versuchen lösungen zu
finden
herr strack frau bundeskanzlerin eine
frage thema kroner und zum
internationalen engagement deutschlands
impfstoff nach wie vor dem test durch
die ema es gibt von diesem impfstoff
bereits produzierte schaffen
er ist in seiner wirkung schlechter als
die in deutschland verwendeten impfstoff
schützt zum beispiel 200 prozent
tatsächlich vor dem tod durch krone
falls die gema die jüngsten fall diese
den impfstoff eingehen würde würden sie
dafür plädieren den deutschen anteil der
reserviert ist am 250 millionen
einheiten impfstoff einheiten weg ließ
den deutschen anteil nach lateinamerika
zu geben nach lateinamerika als
entwicklungshilfe zu geben in einer
region die zurzeit dramatisch von kroner
getroffen ist und würden sich auch in
der deckung ziehen durch das
paul-ehrlich-institut eventuell selber
dem staub prüfen zu lassen dann zur
verfügung zu stellen
denn die notwendigkeit den jetzt selber
zu prüfen sehe ich nicht weil ich glaube
dass das bei der ema in guten händen ist
und zweitens egal welchen stoff wir
jetzt als anteil haben wir haben ja uns
verpflichtet dass die impfdosen die wir
nicht brauchen und wir haben uns jetzt
erstmal auf 30 millionen festgelegt aber
das kann vielleicht auch mehr sein dass
wir die weitergeben an afrikanische
länder an länder lateinamerikas oder was
auch immer werden wollen mit kovacs im
wesentlichen zusammen arbeiten und haben
da ja auch erhebliche finanzielle
beiträge geleistet das heißt wir werden
jetzt nicht versuchen aufs impfstoffen
sitzen zu bleiben und anderen keinen
impfstoff zu geben sondern wir werden
kalkulieren was brauchen wir für uns wir
werden in absehbarer zeit auch die
notwendigkeit haben dass insbesondere
ältere menschen noch mal
dritter nach impfung bekommen aber so
wie wir impfstoff bestellt haben werden
wir auch im stoff übrig haben und den
werden man nicht hier wären wir immer
schnellstmöglich auch anderen zur
verfügung stellen aber eine sonder
zulassung jetzt für sie nur durch dieses
paul-ehrlich-instituts ich nicht und
auch keine notwendigkeit dafür
zumal ja sehen wo auf der ganzen welt
schon verteilt
eine frage die uns online gestellt wurde
von daniel haas vom handelsblatt das
stichwort des hochwasserschutz er
schreibt die bundesregierung habe gut
drei jahre gebraucht um ein
hochwasserschutz plan zu erstellen es
habe viele widerstände gegeben und nun
einen kompromiss und die frage ist wie
bewerten sie angesichts der neuerlichen
naturkatastrophe diesen politischen
prozess und das ergebnis und was man
sich da in zukunft ändern ja deren
bisherige hochwasserschutz hat sich ja
auch sehr stark an den
länderübergreifenden flüssen orientiert
war elbe reihen und ähnliche dinge da
müssen wir die ergebnisse hängen ja
nicht nur von der bundesregierung ab
sondern die hängen dann auch immer von
den gesprächen mit den ländern ab jetzt
haben wir ganz andere form von
hochwasser gehabt in dem sinne dass dort
wo man eigentlich an hochwasser auch
gewöhnt waren kleineren flüssen die ja
nicht die begradigung zu beklagen hatten
sondern durchaus noch ihre natürlichen
verläufe dass dort exorbitantes
hochwasser aufgetreten ist und welche
schlussfolgerungen daraus man zieht das
muss man jetzt sehen ich habe heute
gerade berichte gelesen wo man sich eben
vorbereitet hat seit das bei einem
hochwasser von drei meter siebzig man
nochmal 50 cm drauf gibt wenn dann
nachher zum schluss zweieinhalb meter
höher sein müssen da muss es jetzt eine
vollkommen neue noch mal nachgedacht
werden wie kann man solche
wir sehen da schutzvorrichtungen
überhaupt aus das problem dieses
hochwassers war ja dass die menschen vor
ort gar nicht glauben konnten als ich
war da in schuld da war das höchste
hochwasser- irgendwie 370 gewesen und
jetzt waren es acht meter 80 oder 87 und
das entzog sich der der
vorstellungskraft auch der menschen vor
ort da sind verschiedenste schwierige
faktoren glaube ich zusammengekommen die
verstopften brücken die gästen bot böden
und vieles andere mehr also das muss
aufgearbeitet werden und werden dann
auch die schlussfolgerungen daraus
gezogen
frau merkel noch mal eine frage zurück
zur 2 sie verteidigen gerade strengsten
von mit den usa in osteuropa wird das
aber durchaus als solches geschenk an
putin schon heute bezeichnet weil es
eine klare partner interessen
priorisierung sichtbar macht ist am ende
wert auf hat zukommt ankommt ist am ende
für deutschland als partner russland
wichtige als ukraine und polen nein
überhaupt nicht
das darum geht es nicht sondern es geht
darum für ein projekt das in seiner
politischen bewertung unterschiedlich
gesehen wird von verschiedenen ländern
kompromiss wege zu finden und ich glaube
durch dieses statement werden die wird
die situation für die ukraine die wir
unterstützen und die ich nun auch ganz
persönlich immer unterstützt habe werden
die schwerpunkte richtig gesetzt und
deshalb ist dieses statement aus meiner
sicht auch für die ukraine gute
nachfrage stellen
ich hab's verhalten nicht so richtig
verstanden wie sie meinte wäre also wenn
es zu keiner verlängerung dieses
transitvertrag mit kleiner kommt wäre
das für sie ein punkt der ausreichen
würde um sanktionen
einzuberufen oder wir es noch nicht was
wäre wenn solche fragen möchte ich nicht
beantworten und habe ich es nie
beantwortet sondern ich sage wir
verpflichten uns mit der mit russland
und das werden wir auch gemeinsam mit
europa machen darüber zu sprechen wie
auch über 2024 hinaus einen vertrag
geschafft werden kann
ich habe schon erlebt dass bei dem
vortrag oder die verlängerung fällt er
nie schaffen und wir haben uns dann da
sehr eingesetzt und haben dafür auch
sehr viel gearbeitet und haben sie
geschafft und jetzt gehe ich so daran
dass ich das auch wieder schaffen will
oder ich hoffe dass diejenigen die mir
nachfolgen das genauso mit dem iphone
machen
wir haben die nächste frage hier vorn
mit einem blick auf die uhr muss ich
sagen dass ein paar kolleginnen und
kollegen definitiv heute nicht mehr dran
kommen wenn wir uns mit kurzen und eher
kurzen fragen und antworten ist schaffen
könnten wir vielleicht den kollegen hier
fahren dann noch herr ziegler und herrn
braune schaffen also bitte
diese regelungen keinen bestand haben
verlieren sie diese auffassung habe
einen fehler gemacht und ein
grundsätzlicher wir werden die ich sehe
da keinen sechser kurz und h und ich
teile die meinung von armin laschet
bezüglich der tatsache dass man nicht
sagen kann 100 prozent soll der mieter
tragen und 0 prozent der vermieter und
sagt wir haben als bundesregierung einen
anderen vorschlag gemacht der hat in der
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion kein keine
mehrheit gefunden er ist auch recht
holzschnittartig nämlich 50 50 die
wahrheit ist und dann muss die lösung
gefunden werden das aber nicht ganz
unkompliziert wenn ich ein vermieter
habe der alles getan hat um die
bestmögliche energieeffizienz für die
vermietete wohnung zu finden dann ist
von da an natürlich sehr mieter mehr in
der verantwortung was den stromverbrauch
zum beispiel angeht als wenn ich ein
vermieter habe der nichts in die
sanierung seiner wohnung was die
energieeffizienz anbelangt investiert
hat mit einer 50 50 regelung tue ich so
als ob alle vermieter gleich sind und
alle häuser gleich sind und das ist
natürlich von der realität weit entfernt
und deshalb muss man und das so dass es
nicht so bürokratisch wird und da ist
uns bis jetzt noch nichts gutes
eingefallen deshalb muss man versuchen
verschiedene klassen von vermieteten
wohnungen zu finden die eben energetisch
saniert oder nicht saniert sind und
danach dann auch die beteiligung des
mieters regeln und das ist bis jetzt
nicht gelungen
diese dieser regierung glaube ich will
dazu nichts mehr einfallen sondern das
muss sehr schnell dann in den
koalitionsverhandlungen bearbeitet
werden das jetzt ist ja der co2 preis
auch noch nicht so hoch dass daraus so
dramatische ungleichgewichte entstehen
denn wir haben ja auch die eeg-umlage
abgesenkt das heißt der vermieter
profitiert auch wieder von der mieter
profitiert von der senkung der
eeg-umlage aber wenn wir schrittweise
steigerungen des co2 preis haben dann
wird es ein größeres problem und bis
dahin muss das gelöst seien sehr
einverstanden sind frau bundeskanzlerin
wurde ich ein zimmer und hellbraune noch
die chance geben und dann dann ist die
frageliste tatsächlich geschlossen herr
ziegler auf der von uns aus gesehen
rechten seite
naja die bilanzen im allgemeinen sollten
andere machen und die werden sich dann
auch das wird auch stattfinden ich habe
ja heute schon einige zahlen genannt was
sich verändert hat und ich freue mich
einfach dass wir von über fünf millionen
arbeitslosen heute trotz großer
herausforderung wirtschaftlicher art und
da drei millionen sind dass wir gerade
bei der jugendarbeitslosigkeit
eigentlich ganz gut dastehen da müssen
wir aber auch gucken dass das so bleibt
und mein letzter schwerwiegender fehler
den hab ich ja vor ihnen allen bekannte
mit der oster ruhe
der ist noch präsent in meinem
gedächtnis und zum abschluss der braune
ich glaube dass es richtig war dass wir
jetzt einen haushalt aufgestellt haben
seitens der regierung noch mit auch
einer mittelfristigen finanzplanung bis
2025 geht die unter den auspizien oder
unter der geltung der schuldenbremse
gemacht wurde und dass es hat meine
volle zustimmung gefunden
dann danke ich ihnen heute für die
flexibilität bei den fragestellungen
bitte die technischen fehler zu
entschuldigen
das wollten wir nicht und ich danke vor
allen dingen auch im frau
bundeskanzlerin das stimmt warum
eigentlich dass es ihre letzte sommer
pressekonferenz war das unser büro was
immer sehr präzise arbeitet hat
nachgezählt das war ihre 29 der
bundespressekonferenz wie lange sie im
amt sind welche aktuellen gelegenheiten
es noch gibt wissen wir nicht insofern
sage ich gerne alle guten dinge sind
auch 30 wir würden auch den ton
reparieren sage aber für heute schluss
und dankeschön keine weiteren
versprechungen aber ich sage auch
dankeschön es war mir eine freude